this video is brought to you by ren
[Music]
what's up guys michael here to unpack
the wild two-part finale of season five
of rick and morty the last two episodes
dropped back to back putting a bow on a
season that's been a little all over the
place featuring incisive commentary on
things like climate change and
objectively dumb detour into incestual
space babies and a lot of bird-based
content in between and not to reveal
ourselves as overly predictable
political philosophy nerds but episode
10 had our ears perking up when the show
explicitly talked about capitalism it's
a metaphor for capitalism morty what do
you think
twice wow i thought my capitalism
metaphor was on the nose so what are the
writers trying to say and is what
they're saying actually smart and above
all did it effectively tie up this wild
season let's find out in this quick take
on rick and morty are we free to imagine
and as always spoilers ahead
but before we get into it i want to give
a shout out to this video sponsor ren if
you're paying attention which you
presumably are then you're nodes
outgrowing more and more concerned about
climate change and many folks are
wondering what they can do and
specifically how they can cut back on
their own carbon footprint rent is a
website that helps you calculate your
carbon footprint and then shows you how
you can offset your footprint by funding
projects that do things like plant trees
and protect rainforest ren knows that
you might not have the time and energy
to spend your weekends getting sweaty
and dirty planting trees so they make it
easy for you to help fund those projects
i was excited to learn about ren's
biochar in california project which
removes dead trees from redwood forests
with high fire risk and turns them into
biochar a stable form of carbon that
lasts for thousands of years as someone
that lives in california it feels good
to know that ren has projects that
directly impact important local issues
so to get started all you have to do is
answer a few questions about your
lifestyle and wren will calculate your
carbon footprint and help you reduce it
sadly a zero carbon lifestyle is
impossible but ren can help you offset
what's left over once you sign up to
make a monthly contribution that will be
used to offset your carbon footprint
you'll receive monthly updates from the
projects you support so you will
actually see the impact that you are
making we all know it's going to take a
lot of work to slow down the climate
crisis so why not start today we've
partnered with ren to plant 10 extra
trees for the first 100 people who sign
up using our referral link so go to
www.ren.comwisecrack4
to join us in saving the rainforest and
fighting the climate crisis that's ren
dot co slash start slash wisecrack four
and now back to the show now this season
of rick and morty arguably more than
ever before is really focused on
relationships between characters and are
those relationships healthy of course
they aren't things are just as toxic as
ever between rick and morty rick and the
rest of the smith family and rick and a
recently resurrected bird person just to
name a few most obviously morty is stuck
in rick's endless cycle of abuse
summer you [ __ ] idiot we're not
decoys why did i get punished he's
constantly belittled with rick even
replacing him as a sidekick with a pair
of crows which he picked through a
price's right style spinning wheel just
to be a dick i never said you're
worthless in fact i've given you a very
clear metric of your worth two crows
what's more rick only seems to care
about morty when he can get something
out of him hell the entire reason they
adventure together is because morty's
dumb little brain provides rick cover to
hide from his enemies in the multiverse
when a rick is with a morty the genius
waves get canceled out by the uh
morty waves their relationship seems to
be largely transactional so when morty
does break away from rick in these most
recent episodes and seemingly bonds with
this guy nick via their portal orifices
it seems like he's finally found a
partner who will respect and value him
but not so fast eventually we find out
that nick was also just using morty
specifically to get access to rick's
fancy tech morty has to literally
sacrifice a hand to escape this new
abusive relationship all the action of
that movie 127 hours but in three
seconds meanwhile rick starts training
his new pair of winged sidekicks to whom
he serves a similar platter of
condescension and low expectations
seeing them as only valuable for the
various services they can provide and
when we get to the citadel now run by
evil president morty we find a world of
rampant subjugation with hundreds of
gruesome mortys laboring underground to
power a cheerful futuristic metropolis
massive weapon where president morty
lives in well-protected luxury things
only get darker when we learn that tons
of jerry's and beth have been
manipulated into mating in order to
produce ever more mortys to keep the
merry citadel functioning they've
essentially been instrumentalized to
provide an endless supply for the
so-called
morty market so what does all this have
to do with capitalism before you accuse
us of being depressingly obsessed with
the economic system that everyone in pop
culture loves to hate remember that the
show drops the big c word twice
first when rick produces a weird
rick-haired blob who seems to get off on
experiencing rick's battle wounds it's a
metaphor for capitalism morty what do
you think and then it comes up a second
time wow i thought my capitalism
metaphor was on the nose but let's go
back to the blob for a second if we're
to see the show as being sincere or as
sincere you can be about a masochistic
blob we could see the entire citadel as
a critique of capitalist economies a
manifestation of the harshest imaginable
version of the capitalist system it's a
world built and sustained on class
bifurcation i.e the separation of a
society into two separate classes where
one gets to drink wine while the other
never sees the light of day here the
blob gets off on being defamed off of
basically being tortured and abused to
facilitate rick's craven pursuit of
power power he couldn't obtain without a
lower class rick blob to take the
punches for him the show is seemingly
telling us that anyone who wields power
is usually doing so on the backs of
something much uglier indeed each
network of relationships that we see in
the citadel is built upon pure
exploitation a larger scale version of
the kind of exploitative individual
human relationship rick and morty have
shared for all these years unfettered
capitalism here becomes a metaphor for
abusive relationships and it seems like
they might be setting up an infinite
cycle where abusive relationships lead
to exploitative systems which lead to
abusive relationships and so on and this
repeats endlessly in a seemingly
infinite number of dimensions with a
seemingly infinite number of ricks
abusing mortys without owning up to
their cruel behavior none of them have
to be responsible they're all victims of
themselves oh it's so hard to be a
genius in fact we learned that mortys
are literally bred to be forgiving which
reinforces the cycle of abuse geez you
guys really are bred for forgiveness
rick pathologically behaves like a dick
morty pathologically forgives him and so
the cycle can begin again in a universe
dominated by all-powerful ricks there
are only so many ways that any given
morty can behave so many choices he has
and how he responds to his material and
emotional conditions similarly some
critics of capitalism argue that the
economic system thrives by offering all
of us plebes the illusion of choice
while simultaneously limiting our
imaginations for what is possible this
is what scholar mark fisher identified
as capitalist realism i.e the widespread
sense that not only is capitalism the
only viable political and economic
system but also that it is now
impossible even to imagine a coherent
alternative to it this seems
contradictory since so much of
capitalism is based on supposedly
rational actors making choices about how
to interact in the free market and sure
there's a free market we can pick from
any of hundreds of health care plans but
chances are most of those plans will
cost about 33 of your income so how much
choice do we really have and like most
people most mortys don't see any choice
other than to work within the system our
central morty accepts a world where rick
has power over him while constantly
trying to convince rick to practice
basic human decency morty's stuck in his
own cycle of forgiveness of rick's abuse
followed by hope that rick will
eventually do better his choices are
severely limited by the relationship
structure created by rick's evil genius
that's where evil morty comes in
motivated by the emotional damage of
seeing rick instrumentalize morty after
morty for his own purposes he seeks to
break out of this infinite loop to
imagine an existence outside of the rick
mandated universe is where a blue-headed
geriatric jerk runs things good morty
versus evil morty's approach to the
problem of rick's abuse is like the
difference between asking your
exploitative boss to treat you better
versus seeking out a new universe where
bosses don't exist evil marty is
obviously otherwise super evil it's
hardly incidental that his goals are
dependent on the forced labor of
hundreds of other abused mortys but can
we really break these cycles of abuse
and arguably abusive social conditions
that can accompany capitalism the show
investigates that question in several
ways first we see rick unexpectedly form
an empathetic relationship with his
crow's sidekicks when he learns how
smart and badass they are rick stops
seeing his bird friends as mere tools to
serve his ends and sees their intrinsic
value problem solved right not so fast
we eventually find out that the crows
were actually using rick as a rebound
after breaking up with a very horny
scarecrow what do you mean using me as a
rebound this relationship had always
been transactional and morty seeks out
equality in his friendship with nick who
it turns out was just using him too the
show seems to suggest that even the most
apparently heartwarming relationships
still can't transcend systems of
transaction and exploitation except for
maybe beth and jerry but that's a topic
for another day dr wong suggested we
experiment we've been watching
pornography together i might never come
back and then we get to evil morty who's
characterized as evil not because he's
turned everyone's portal guns into
murder machines but specifically because
he wants to break out of the rick ruled
system but this raises a question what
if evil morty's desire to break free is
the one good thing about him arguably
he's freeing his imagination to consider
not just making improvements to the
citadel's brutal reality but tearing the
whole thing down and freeing himself the
show even makes the limitations of
imagination inside rick's version of
reality literal through the central
finite curve which separates all the
universes where rick is the smartest
from all the universes where he's not on
the side of the curve we know rick will
always abuse morty will always forgive
and there's no alternative to this
system some scholars would call this
analogous to the way we view capitalism
in contemporary society any variation on
capitalism is possible heck the united
states will even demand it from certain
countries in exchange for humanitarian
aid but while you can revise capitalism
any which way the adage attributed to
frederick jameson remains it is easier
to imagine the end of the world than the
end of capitalism but the show
eventually seems to suggest that evil
morty's search for a reality outside the
cycle of exploitation is a valuable goal
with the season concluding as he blast
into a different unknown universe
presumably not run by any version of
rick so maybe the show's writers are
once again using the animated multiverse
to get us to reflect on some of the
nihilistic tendencies baked into our own
society maybe they're digging even
deeper into the dark depths of rick's
relationship to morty or was this just a
way to cram five seasons worth of canon
and lore into a couple of episodes so
the next season they can just get back
to dark wacky serialized adventures i
guess we'll all have to wait and see but
what do you guys think is rick and morty
slyly critiquing capitalism or just
throwing us off dissent with the
occasional reference what's next for
evil morty and is there any real
alternative to capitalism let us know
your thoughts in the comments big thanks
to our patrons for all your support hit
that subscribe button like you're
milking your own clone for blood and
don't forget to ring that bell and as
always thanks for watching later
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]